unfortunately we can't plead the fifth
in trash taste episodes which i would
love to do because i don't really know
how to describe music very well okay i
will establish that very early on
yeah see we've established that with
connor but uh i also have been [ __ ]
myself with the thought of this episode
and especially when it came to like
picking my choices one it was super
difficult because i didn't know like
i didn't know how to describe why
i liked like the pics that i picked i
just know that they were important to me
at a time in mind we got to see why we
like it oh i'm [ __ ]
i guess like what on what basis did you
pick it because it's like i i guess gone
was saying that like it was an important
like important artist in your life right
yeah mine is also kind of based on that
in a sense
yeah
okay actually first question how did you
boys what what uh what
what method did you use to like pick
your artist
do i remember the artist's name i'll put
it down yeah yeah yeah because because
actually like
my biggest difficulty right is that i
like a lot of songs
but i don't know if i like a lot of
artists you know like i like like i like
certain songs from certain artists but
like i i feel like i'm more like i get
into genres of music or like i get into
like a certain genre then more than i
get into this one specific artist or
this one specific band and if i do it's
like very very very rare
i think that's pretty normal it's like
food you know it's like i like french
food i don't like all french food yeah
yeah so it's like
that's the way i see it but i do like
all mexican food it's pretty [ __ ]
good yeah so i guess we'll see that's
kind of how i view it for me it was like
for me it was like i'll
you know i couldn't just like reach into
the nether and grab a band because i'm
sure if i did i if i did that i'm sure
there'd be like a million other bands
that i just completely forgot about so i
was like all right i'll split it into
genres so i was like all right i like
metal music
[ __ ]
that didn't make it any easier i'm like
like spongebob writing the with my first
thought my first four picks i'm like so
confident like oh this one oh that one
okay oh this one okay wait what else do
i listen to
yeah i i literally went okay so uh you
know we had our first four or five picks
that was you know easy came to our head
and then like i went through my spotify
to try and see if i could narrow down
anything else that i could like talk
about or was important to me and the
more i scrolled the more i'm just like
what the [ __ ] is my music taste what
what is actually this like collection of
songs that i've put together that
defines who i am i like i try to
psychoanalyze this and i'm like i don't
know what the [ __ ] what the [ __ ] that's
what i love about doing these three by
three episodes is that more so than our
audience trying to figure out what our
tastes are we find out what our own
tastes are like i already want to change
some of my picks but we'll go with it
we'll go well some of my picks were like
i chose one band but it was more of just
like i wanted to pick one band just to
just just to talk about talk about
several bands that i want to put in this
spot get those excuses out now yeah yeah
yeah get them out set them up
oh yeah this one this was that orphan
that one time that i saved he loved this
song and i i also loved it
yeah i don't know i i guess i guess it's
been it's like now that i think about it
i have like such a different
relationship to music than i do to like
other forms of media you know like i
have like really games that i could talk
about forever about like why i really
[ __ ] like this game same thing with
movies same thing with anime obviously
but but like with music's always been
this one enigma for me because music's
just been this one thing where i like
certain things i don't know why i like
it i just like it it's because most
people when they listen to music
i just like it no explanation
i think it's just because like most
people when they listen to music don't
think that deeply about what they're
listening to like there isn't a guy that
like runs into the room and is like
explain what you're listening to right
now it's like
the drums are good yeah yeah
when someone's like what's your taste in
music you can just be like uh
metal you know you don't respond yeah
yeah yeah and then i was like okay
that's it right yeah like when people
ask me what am i tasting music is i'm
just like
yes yes i like socks i like everything i
like like i like songs i hate i hate
being that guy who just goes i like a
bit of everything
it's just like the generic answer but i
really literally don't know how to
answer that question aside from yeah i
like a bit of everything should we
should we stop giving excuses to
ourselves
this is this is it oh we're going to do
trash box going yeah bringing back trash
yes all right so i guess i don't want
joey to go first
i don't want to go first either because
i don't want i don't want to follow joey
i don't want to have joey
like
give him this [ __ ] presentation his
powerpoint with animations i don't know
why he likes my metallica
my goal for this uh episode is to not be
that pretentious music so we need you to
be that pretty i don't want to be that
prediction because because you need to
like counteract me and conor going
i like the beeps and the boobs and i'm
being like well the the voice sounded
nice i like the voice and i'm just like
i like the voice
oh it's it's called corner first okay
perfect all right this is going to be
tough all right
this is like my mom's going to walk in
and there's just [ __ ] everywhere and i'm
like
listen i can explain
this has a reason
this is a weird three by three i think
yeah some of them you'll expect some of
them you won't also i chose i try to
choose a funny image for some of them i
can think of at least three bands that's
good that's good yeah can you actually
can you really yeah i thought only one
no no there's at least think of
definitely one
no i can i can think of at least story
all right we'll find out all right let's
find out
the image i chose for the weekend
where did you get that image of the
weekend that's like the famous picture
this is a weird one okay yeah i got i
got the three that i thought oh okay
that's okay yeah that's good what was
the three that you thought i knew daft
punk entertainment power that's right i
knew he was gonna put that on which
jerry knows i love taylor and paula yeah
yeah joey knows that and yeah yeah uh
okay bo burnham on the left yeah i gotta
probably burn i'm gonna watch oh okay oh
yeah yeah yeah uh
that shouldn't surprise me do you know
this is kind of like we'll get into this
yeah right
this is more about silly pop in general
okay okay
i don't think i know the rest uh this is
uh parcels
castles yeah so they're kind of not well
known but it's very similar vibes to
daft punk plus this is a breakbot over
there you know breakbot you don't know
you know breakbot i know their song
though you know the the baby i'm yours
the the ladies and gentlemen we got him
song oh that's that's breakpoint that's
breakpoint okay the rest of their songs
are amazing okay i've listened to some
of their music i'd like their songs
[ __ ] slap yeah
[Music]
have you ever listened to that song
without it being bass booster
i don't really know that song
okay so i mean there's not much i guess
the band i listen to the most it's
definitely these five are the ones i
listen to right now yeah right i love
the weekend yeah so you also dropped the
new album and i i [ __ ] love that
album that's a great album i guess who
do i want to talk about first who should
i talk about who do you want me to um
that's i guess you've talked about who's
the parcels
yeah yeah let's talk about parcels
because i don't think gone right so
they're a band right now i believe okay
okay this is gonna be hard to talk about
because i don't know a lot about a lot
of these people all i know is that i
play their music an awful lot i think
they're a band
that is based in germany i don't think
they are german okay they live in
germany and they do kind of like it's
very like funk but also oh how do i
describe music to people i only know
people because like the guy the guy in
like and i can literally see connor's
like brain cells committing suicide as
he's like trying to process i'm not
gonna lie like i looked at this picture
of parcels and the guy at the back in
the middle looks like george harrison
yeah he's weird right yeah they look
like beetles if they were around today i
don't know how to explain it it's like
they don't
i don't know uh parcels are an
australian electoral pop oh there are
also electrical policies
there we go oh okay okay
electric
electro pop there we go
you know a lot of the things you can see
like the influence of like if you look
deaf punk in the middle kind of like
little parts of death they've
experimented in yeah that's probably
where i like because it's like i think
my favorite uh def punk album is like
discovery which i've put there yeah yep
but i don't think there's many songs in
death point i don't like right even the
first album is probably the one i don't
like the most because it's very like
more experimental as opposed to the
other stuff they did yeah it's a lot
more like rudimentary for sure and a lot
some of the songs in the first album i
cannot remember the name of the first
album the one with the am on the front
of it literally i think it might just be
cool yeah i mean i feel like i only
started listening to daft punk after
like was it the homework album
homework was the first one where i
properly got into darth punk as well i
think that's why most people got into
dark parts like yeah the homework or
discovery well i think it was like was i
think the first big hit was around the
world wasn't there yeah yeah that was
that was like what put them on the map
which is the most repetitive song in
existence
yeah what's it what's the album you have
to fact check me on a lot of this we're
gonna need a lot of fractures
everyone behind the camera
we need like seven fact checkers right
now
collaborating with dark punk on their
2017 single overnight i didn't even know
that oh there you go that's that's
probably where that's probably where why
because a lot of these artists that i
find that i've no idea who they are it's
like youtube recommends me yeah you know
who i'm surprised is not on your three
by three joji jojo i don't listen to
joji that much every time i go to your
house you're playing joji that is true
that is true i've played a lot of i
think i had faces of joji like i like
joji a lot you know like i like joji a
lot but that just sounds like a man
i love joji's music but there's only
like four songs that i actually listen
to the rest of the album i don't really
like i think at least for the first five
i've listened to like everything from
tame impala weekend deaf punk breakbot
yeah uh parcels i've listened to like
everything and like so the parcels deaf
punk and breakbot i can just put on
their albums yeah yeah any any song and
i'll have a good time and i'm like this
is great like i'm in a car those are the
three i'm playing so this is all like
recent taste then or
within the past five years unfortunately
my my tastes haven't really changed much
in the past six years it's kind of like
i have phases where i go into something
else but it always comes back to that
type of music what did you listen to
when you were a kid yeah that's a good
question well right in the bottom uh
bottom right is biffy clattered jeffy
claro no idea no idea who biffy i don't
know about that album cover is cool
right yeah i said before is a scottish
rock band yeah okay um and
uh they've done they've done us they're
viral
scottish they've supported for foo
fighters a few times oh okay so like if
you like foo fighters yeah and you want
a more scottish version of foo fighters
oh and i might be butchering and doing
an absolute disservice to buffy flowers
but i like foo fighters a lot and the
way i found them is that a lot of my
friends in school really liked food
fighters and were when we were growing
up that's the stuff they like and then i
got into biffy clara from that and i
went to watch them live that was the
first concert i ever went to a buffy
clara concert yeah it was amazing i
loved it so much and uh i don't know i
would say uh this is a good album to
listen to they had the really famous one
that came out before this i can't
remember the name of it it's got like
two big colors on the front of it
i've got the name of it today's do they
sing in like a scottish accent as well
yeah so that's what i love about them
you know sometimes a lot of bands where
they're like from scotland but they just
sound american somehow yeah yeah but
it's like actually like
oh yeah you're done
like that
you're looking for is only revolution
that's it
first album was uh homework yeah
oh [ __ ] i thought am came forward my bad
faked so it was that first album
no no no no no no random actors it's
probably like an ep or something yeah it
might have been yeah oh my bad then yeah
i must have made it that's that's what
that's what i want more bands to do
though because like the one thing like
seeing in the accent of the country that
they're from you should yeah i think
you'd quite like biffy clowns that's
what i love about life that's what i
love about like proclaimers right
because like when they sing the 500 mile
song they couldn't sound any more
[ __ ] scottish than that song right
yeah
i find it so weird when i like hear an
artist right and you hear you hear them
sing right and then you hear them speak
and there is like such a dissonance
between how they sing and how they speak
i remember one of the first time i heard
adele speak right and it's like the most
northern accent
why are you surprised you're british
because like she doesn't sound like
anything like that when she sings you
know probably for good reason
could you imagine an adele song in the
accent that she's facing like there's no
way she would have blown up because no
one would have been able to understand
what she was through the rain
but like they're like
getting dragged rubbing in the deep
rolling in the deep i
that she am have popped off i'm sorry
because like like i had i had no idea
she was uh she was british until until i
heard her speak and she was then i was
like oh this is
the most northern person i've ever heard
speak in my life and i feel a lot of
australian artists are like that too
like sia for example is like the most
australian sound
interviews but when she sings everyone
thinks
damn we like lose our accents for some
reason i don't know why
yeah like we can't like i i find it hard
to i guess do an accent but it's not
hard for some reason it's less hard to
sing an accent i don't know it's yeah
it's weird right that's i find it easier
to sing in an american accent than i do
speak in an american accent i don't
understand at all
how it works
i know how accents were i don't know i
don't know how it works when you sing
though it's a different register i think
that's that's why when i hear an accent
in a song i it immediately like just
sticks out to me i guess because you
always hear like the neutral american
accent with like a lot of songs so yeah
when you hear an accent that is just
anything that's not like the
stereotypical neutral american accent it
immediately just sticks out in my mind
so yeah yeah yeah yeah that's what
that's what i want more artists to do
though because like otherwise like
everyone's just going to sound the
[ __ ] same right and it's like if if
there's the best way to make you as an
artist stand out
is to just sound different like just
just sing in a different accent because
then immediately you'll be like you'll
listen to a beefy clara song and you'll
be like oh they sound scottish must be a
beefy clarison yeah i mean they're very
very scottish when you hear them right
it's fun could you imagine if beefy
clyro like obviously i don't know beefy
claro right but you said they kind of
sound similar to foo fighters uh well
i'd say it's kind of in the same vein
it's uh like kind of feeling of the way
they say so would you say that if po
chance the beefy clara lead singer
like dave grohl then it would sound like
foo fighters or no no i don't know it's
weird because the songs are so scottish
if you listen to them you'll i think you
might like them they kind of seem like
you're kind of banned actually you're
like you love food fighters right yeah i
love you yeah i think you'll probably
like that i like foo fighters as well
then you'll probably like them as well
if you like scottish kind of take on it
again i i must be offending like big
massive fans massive
fans
that's the only way that i know because
i don't understand how to talk about
music like a normal human being yeah so
there's any way i can imagine explaining
it uh but also it was like the only the
first album like i ever bought out of
like like physical i think i only ever
bought like three albums in my life
right right and i think this was the
first one oh i like the effort now i
think about i don't think i've ever
bought an album i love this so much i
remember i loaded it onto my pc
i don't know i put it on my xbox yeah
yeah and you could play the albums on
xbox while playing another game
i would open up that [ __ ]
menu the [ __ ] big one yeah yeah yeah
and the volume was just dreadfully like
not managed correctly so i'm playing
modern warfare 2 and just throw it out
with your feelings
like that it was like it's great it was
awesome i had i had a i had a cd player
like the [ __ ] like chunky no i had
one of those two yeah yeah
you know what's the first album i bought
on
what [ __ ] simple plan
classic joke that album slaps i don't
care what anyone says